hi everyone I'm Jonathan Johnson today I
have another tactical puzzle so when you
see it on your screen go ahead pause
your video and let's see if you can
solve this week's puzzle this is a
position that was reached in Tata Steel
2014 between pentola Hari Krishna and
Hikaru Nakamura and in this position
Nakamura played a very innocent-looking
move Queen to c5 attacking the rook
bringing the Queen towards the center
but clearly overlooked a very fantastic
move that Hari Krishna has hidden in
this position so go ahead pause your
videos and see if you can find this very
remarkable continuation in this position
white played Knight h5 he's aiming for
those dark squares especially f6 and
this is actually big trouble for black
notice that the knight and the rook are
both hanging but you can't actually take
them without getting made it so in the
game Picardo tried Bishop to g7 so we'll
come back and look at that the other
options are no good if you take on a7
for example now our knight can come into
have six and after your King moves we
can swap bishops threatening Queen to h6
so you don't have time to grab the
bishop because if the Queen enters the
game mate on h7 is unstoppable also
going back to the initial position here
taking the knight also leads to a quick
checkmate opening the G file allowing
the White Queen to be introduced to the
black King he can't possibly survive an
attack like this and indeed it does lead
to a very quick checkmate
so in the game hikaru with no good
choices he tried to defend with the move
Bishop to g7 but now after we take here
we're still threatening to bring the
Queen in to h6 and the knight can go to
g5 so there's lots of trouble here on
the dark squares so after f5 he's trying
to make some space for his King to run
away Knight g5 seals the door and the
black King will get mated in just a
couple moves here
thank you everybody for watching let me
know in the comments below were you able
to solve this one go ahead give it a big
thumbs up and I'll see you guys next
week for another tactical challenge